Argy is Matthew V's serendipitous action
film starring his daughter's cat among
many other notable stars like dualipa
and Henry Cavill there was even a theory
that the book this film is based on was
actually written by Taylor Swift the
mystery has yet to be revealed and it's
uncertain if we'll ever find out the way
this movie came about was very
serendipitous for director Matthew vaugh
during lockdown it was the first time I
could actually get the family to watch
movies together he put on movies like
charade and Romancing the Stone the
movies that continue to inspire his
style of film making most of my movies
are always I call them a love letter to
the movies I love as a kid or which I
felt could be reinvented so when he and
his family were watching these classic
mystery type movies his daughter asked
why they don't make movies like this
currently with sarin divy came I I read
the book well the manuscript of the book
and met with fuks from there he decided
he would base the movie around book four
and he's hoping to film book one one as
the sequel so let's talk about the plot
really quick the story is about a
character named Ellie who writes a
fictional emphasis on fictional spy
novel that hits a little too close to
home with some actual real life spies so
she ends up getting targeted for leaking
confidential information Ellie's main
character Argyle doesn't exist but there
is Aiden wild who ends up saving her
from these dangerous enemies gunning for
her as she watches Aiden fight off her
offenders she keeps imagining Argyle in
his place so Sam Rockwell who plays
Aiden and Henry Cavill who plays Argyle
had to film the same exact fight scenes
to the tea literally the same exact
movements down to the breath they had to
watch each other closely when
choreographing intense fight scenes
Henry talked to ew about the fight scene
on the train quote certain movements
worked better for him so I would mimic
those and then different movements in
other places worked better for me so he
would copy those it was also dangerous
and tricky having to do everything in
such a cramped space let's talk about
dualipa this is her first big acting
debut we did get to see her Cameo and
Barby but technically Argy was shot
before that her character also holds a
lot of weight in the eyes of Matthew
vaugh I needed someone that could hold
the screen with Henry Cavell and then
blow him off that's not an easy feat but
Matthew was inspired to cast dualipa
because of his kids influence I didn't
know who J was you know I'm getting old
and they played me the music and then I
saw an interview with her he was so
impressed with her interview and the way
she carried herself and it was such a
ridiculous dress but it still looked
great and and meaning she just pulled it
off he set up a meeting with her and
Henry and apparently the chemistry was
off the charts so the rest was history
there were a lot of challenges when it
came to creating this film but
surprisingly at the top of the list was
filming with a cat yep you heard that
right not the intense action or fight
scenes but working with a cat I now love
cats I hate the cats before this movie
The cat in the movie was actually his
daughter's cat because he fired the
first cat after a day of filming know
and I fired the first cat after a day of
filming and I literally went my I'm
going to borrow a cat he ended up
borrowing his daughter's cat for 3
months driving him to work every morning
and housing him in his trailer he's he's
he's the star of the house now also
another major challenge had to do with
Co shooting with masks made everything
take a lot longer than it would have
otherwise it was very hard making a
movie everyone wearing masks
something else that was surprising about
this movie was its length when Matthew
vaugh was editing it it kept getting
shorter and shorter as editing does but
the notes he kept getting about the
length were pretty bizarre quote we put
the shorter version in front of an
audience and we got the note it's a
little too long I felt it was a little
longer as well but it was shorter I was
like this is bizarre what's going on
what he ended up realizing is that
audiences and himself were able to
ingest the longer version of the film
EAS easier than the shorter version
quote the longer cut it new when to
breathe and this other one it couldn't
breathe so when you can't breathe you're
conscious of time it was the first time
in his entire career he ever made a
movie longer because he hates long
movies it seems as though Matthew vau
outdid himself and his patience when it
came to training his daughter's cat to
be a star dual lippa's big debut is
going to leave fans Wonder struck by her
inevitable stage presence Sam Rockwell
is learning action moves from season
stars like Henry caval for some major
onscreen moments and fans can
undoubtedly expect a major sequel
inspired by book one what was your
favorite behind the scenes moment